I don't know if you know this about me
I'm kind of did like trippy things and I
like lucid dreaming and they told me
that you actually do some lucid dream
well I don't I first of all I didn't
even know it was called that so I'm
assuming everyone knows but for those
who know that's where you can you know
your dream you realize you're dreaming
but you don't wake up so you but in your
dream you know you're dreaming so you
then can control it right which is to me
it's great oh yes but I had a dream
where ice I could swear I was not
dreaming
that's the thing you want to do whatever
you want to do but then what if I'm not
dreaming so I but the other night I had
a that is like the explanation of so
many random crimes and stuff that was a
drink yes well but I found I found the
way to fix that in my dream I was this
is a true story I was having the dream
and I said well not dream I was on the
golf course and I go why I've been on
this golf course I know I'm not dreaming
so I can this is real I go well let me
just check and in the dream I jumped up
in the air to see if I could hover and
and I could hover and I said I am dry
now I know I'm dreaming let's have sex
with everyone
so that's your test now that's my Tesla
from in an elevator and a beautiful
woman gets in I might she'd like to see
me do a little jump money this is what
not to drop that's not you know it
sounds like I'm saying that when I won
the Emmy I do know a little time ago but
you have it with you it's a long time
ago I was won Emmy you know I couldn't
match my for People's Choice Awards
you're not don't think you're bragging
when you mention all right never know
it's something to brag about
I want to be nominated but we say horse
boner too much huh there's an award show
for that for horse bomber yeah what
happened at the Emmys um she came up
with a great line for me because that
day she we were getting ready for the
Emmys and again we've been married a
long time and my wife said I hope you
win I hope you win tonight but if you do
win and you get on stage and you tell me
you love me in front of everybody don't
think that makes up for never saying it
when we're alone that's and I use that
exact line or she comes up she comes up
with the material for me yeah
Anana good show ask but there's my wife
translate ask her if she liked the show
dition yeah see she thought she won
Daisy she thought she was gonna see
Conan
you